[Music]
it's been a big news day here in the
nation's capital and in New York City
where an Isis follower botched a terror
attack a pipe bomb strapped to his chest
malfunctioned after detonation at the
Port Authority subway station one of the
city's main transportation hubs and
surprise surprise he got into America
via wait for it chain migration so isn't
it time to ditch this dangerous policy
finally I'm gonna ask Univision anchor
Jorge Ramos what he thinks of the chain
migration debate in light of today's
events and with accusations of
partisanship surrounding the Muller
investigation former federal prosecutor
Andy McCarthy will be here to explain
how the Muller probe may be missing the
most important Russia story of all but
first the media's desperate attempt to
divert attention from their repeated
screw-ups that's the subject of
tonight's angle it wasn't just another
fake news story attempting to tie
President Trump to Russia CNN's
disgraceful reporting of last week seems
like a watershed moment a blatant
example of the establishment media's
reckless coverage of the so called
Russia collusion story on Friday you'll
recall CNN reported that WikiLeaks tried
to share hacked documents with the Trump
campaign and Don Trump jr.
back in September of 2016 and that
report was quickly picked up by other
news organizations but it turned out
those documents had already been made
public and the dates of the Don jr.
emails reported by CNN were false the
bombshell quickly blew up in CNN's face
CNN never retracted the story but took
five hours to post a correction after it
was debunked on Sunday the host of CNN's
reliable sources
Brian aka shoeless Staedtler refused to
explain how the network got the story so
wrong instead what he did is he tried it
out that old Watergate dinosaur Carl
Bernstein
and the perpetual Trump critic David
Fromm who both ignored the
question of how CNN botched the story
though they did revert to the CNN party
line and well they just attacked the
president the sources weren't trying to
trick the reporters the sources were
just mistaken but that mistake obviously
caused the black eye for CNN journalists
make mistakes our record is journalists
in covering this Trump story and the
Russian story is pretty good especially
compared to the record of Donald Trump
from the president and his supporters
you hit here a system of Lies so they're
not well-placed to complain the worst
mistakes that press organizations have
made in the coverage of Trump has
precisely occurred in their effort
they're overzealous effort to be a fair
to the president wait a second now CNN
concoct a damaging story about the
president and they only did so because
they're trying to be utterly fair to him
I'm not following any of this I need to
buy a major vowel or two the media are
destroying their credibility whatever is
left of it by allowing politics to
dominate editorial decisions and color
their reporting this is no way to build
public confidence and by the way it's
not just CNN ABC's Brian Ross reported
the candidate Trump instructed Michael
Flynn to reach out to the Russians when
it was actually president electrum oops
the Washington Post reporter Dave waggle
let's not forget him
he tweeted a photo from the Trump rally
in Florida on Friday showing lots and
lots of empty seats didn't look good
turns out he took the picture before the
audience had actually entered the arena
that's cute he did apologize later but
not surprisingly polls show the American
public is losing faith and how the media
are covering Trump a Quinnipiac poll
last month found 58% of American voters
disapprove of the way the media covers
the president while only 38% approve 53%
of voters said the media focuses too
much on negative stories about Trump so
the media's answer today more negative
stories about Trump well in an attempt
I think to revive some of their flagging
ratings and maybe distract from their
own journalistic and sex abuse scandals
the network's dragged out Trump accusers
again the president of course has denied
these allegations but that didn't stop
megyn kelly from showcasing them on her
own struggling morning show so much it
for her staying out of politics wasn't
that she said she was going to do well
they then held a press conference
sponsored by a soros bat group called
brave new films peel back the curtain a
little bit brave new films describes
itself as a quick strike media company
that has produced a string of liberal
documentaries establishment media
tripped over themselves to take the bait
in turn today's White House press
briefing into a total circus have you
ever been sexually harassed and do you
understand and I'm not saying about
prison I'm saying ever this is spinning
and it's focused on him now
and he has addressed it directly to the
emeriti trying up new and a French and
more people are now speaking out maybe
I'm gonna keep my understanding on this
this is a huge issue Sarah yeah North
Korea but this is a huge issue yeah it's
a huge issue for a media obsessed with
driving Trump from office at all costs
well now on the day before the Alabama
Senate election as we predicted last
week when Democrats ran out Franken out
of the Senate without so much as a
scheduled hearing senator Kirsten
Gillibrand is calling for President
Trump to resign from office this is a
Craven attempt to weaken the president
with these choreographed allegation
parades but my friends they won't work
but at least now it's easier to see with
whom certain media organizations are
colluding and to what end and that's the
angle